STARTING THE LATE HERE WELCOME
TO THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE HEARING- SOME
ANNOUNCEMENTS FIRST AND THEN
WE'LL HEAR OUR FIRST BILL-
FIRST OF ALL DUE TO THE
CONTINUED STATE HOME ORDER WERE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
HEARING THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. ALSO REQUIRING
THE MASK BE WORN IN FISCAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR AT A VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE HE DID NOT HAVE A MASK WE
CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE
HAVE DIFFERENT A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM. TODAY IN THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH CHAMBER OF IT IS SIMPLY
CHAMBERS WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTENTION OF STAFF ON A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACING THEY'RE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCE
IN PROGRAM OPRAH PROTOCOLS FOR
THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE
THE CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE HERE
IN THIS ROOM ANY MEMBER THE
PUBLIC. IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON A BILL. PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND I'LL ASK YOU
PRO SOME MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE- YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING TO RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE TO SURE TO
OBSERVE FISCAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL. INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. TODAY'S
AGENDA WILL BE TAKEN UP IN THE
ORDER LISTED ON THE AGENDA AND
IN THE DAILY FILE. WITH MEMBERS
WHO ARE NOT ON THE COMMITTEE
FIRST IN ALPHABETICAL ORDER AND
THEN MEMBERS WHO ARE ON THE
COMMITTEE ALSO IN ALPHABETICAL
ORDER WITH THE CHAIR PRESENTING
LAST- IN ADDITION. TO BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME WITH
BILL WITNESSES USING. MAKING
USE OF OUR WITNESS CONFERENCE-
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOMS WHICH
ARE LOCATED HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. AND A REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS. THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THE TESTIMONY LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING
ROOM. AND ALSO ASKING
QUESTIONS. FOR THOSE PEOPLE
DIALING IN WE WILL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE TO
WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY
ON A BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE DAILY HEALTH
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE WEBSITE WORK
AND IN THE DAILY FILE AS WELL
AS ON OUR TV SCREENS. NOT OUR
SHORES. YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON HIS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. AND
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST IN YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE BE ADVISED
THAT IF YOU'RE A MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL. HE WILL
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE AND NEED
TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE
CALLED TO SPEAK. MANY OF
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE. AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE
SEVEN AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY. TO
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL WITH
INSTRUCTIONS ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. AND YOU CAN FIND THE
EMAIL FOR THE COMMITTEE THERE
AS WELL. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT-
METHODS CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. IF YOU LIKE TO RESPOND
TO A ROLL CALL OR ASK A
QUESTION PROVIDE A COMMENT-
PLEASE RAISE YOUR MICROPHONE SO
THE STAFF AN ACTIVATE IT WHEN
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK.
ALSO PLEASE STAND UP AND FACE
THE MICROPHONE WHILE SPEAKING
TO ENSURE YOUR VOICE IS AUDIBLE
IN CAN BE RECORDED. AND MEMBERS
WHO WILL BE NOT BE RECOGNIZED
IF THEY'RE NOT FOLLOWING THE
GUIDANCE OF LEADERSHIP AND
WEARING A FACE COVERING HERE
WHICH I. HAVEN'T SEEN HAPPENED
SO. MUCH APPRECIATED FOR THAT-
IN FAIRNESS EVERYONE WE WILL
NEED TO BE ESPECIALLY STRICT ON
THE TIME LIMITS. WE WILL HEAR
FROM TWO WITNESSES FOR THREE
MINUTES EACH FOR EACH SIDE.
AFTER THE TWO MAY WITNESSES FOR
EACH SIDE TESTIFIED IF THERE
ARE ANY. WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONES AND COMBINE THE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY FOR BOTH
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION SO WE
WILL NOT BE HAVING. SEPARATE
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. UP
COLIN IS GOING TO GOING TO ONE
LINE AND YOU'LL YOU'LL NEED TO
SEE AS- SPECIFIED THAT YOU WERE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. ADDITION DIDN'T DISH NO
WITNESSES- WE BE ASKED WILL BE
LIMITED TO THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF THEY- REPRESENT
ONE AND POSITION ON THE BILL.
SO THAT WITH THAT- GET AROUND
WE STILL ARE. SHORT OF A QUORUM
WE DO HAVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS-ARE PROPOSED TODAY FOR CONSENT
OF BRING THIS UP LATER BUT I'M
I WILL CALL IT OUT NOW- ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB FIVE FORTY ONE BY
MR BERMAN. I ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
EIGHT FORTY EIGHT BY- MISS
CALLED AROUND ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB AT ONE TWELVE BY MR HOLDEN
WITH AMENDMENTS I DECIDED NEVER
SEVEN AB THREE EIGHTY TWO I
MISS COM A SENATOR COM LONGER-
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWO THIRTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMMUS-
ANATOMY NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT BYE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLORIDA. I AND NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB TEN EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON. A
NUMBER ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN- AB
SIX SEVENTY ONE BY MYSELF. AND
NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE WITH IS A HEALTH
COMMITTEE BILL SO WITH THAT WE
WILL MOVE TO- THE FIRST BILL-
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWELVE
TWELVE BY MISTER CHOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN YOU READY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AB TWELVE FIFTY TWO WOULD BRING
HEALTH INFORMATION COLLECTED BY
FDA APPROVED APPLICATIONS USED
AT THE DIRECTION OF A HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER TO BE UNDER THE
PROTECTION OF CALIFORNIA'S
MEDICAL PRIVACY LAW OR C. M. I.
A. THE FDA HAS RECENTLY
STREAMLINED THE PROCESS BY
WHICH DIGITAL HEALTH PRODUCTS
ARE. APPROVED GIVING HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS NEW WAYS TO GET
USEFUL AND ACCURATE INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR PATIENTS. FOR
EXAMPLE SEVERAL FORMS OF
DIGITAL PILLS ALREADY IN USE.
THESE SKILLS COMBINE INGESTIBLE
MICROCHIPS SENSORS WITH
PHARMACEUTICALS AND COMMUNICATE
WITH THE PATCH THAT COLLECTS
INFORMATION AND INSENSITIVE. TO
A MOBILE APPLICATION. THIS
PRODUCT CAN RECORD THE TIME AND
THE QUANTITY OF THE DRUG IS
CONSUMED THE PHYSICAL STATE OF
THE PERSON TAKING THE DRUGS
SUCH AS THE TEMPERATURE
ACTIVITY LEVEL AND HEART RATE.
ALL OF THIS INFORMATION CAN BE
HIGHLY SENSITIVE AND WOOD UNDER
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES BE
PROTECTED UNDER CLIA AND HIPAA.
IN ORDER FOR THIS KIND OF DATA
TO BE CONSIDERED MEDICAL
INFORMATION IT NORMALLY NEEDS
TO BE GENERATED BY HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER. HOWEVER INFORMATION
GENERATED OR COLLECTED BY A
DIGITAL HEALTH APPLICATION
MEETING AT THE PATIENT LEVEL
AND OUTSIDE OF A MEDICAL
FACILITY WILL NOT BE CAPTURE
UNDER THE EXISTING DEFINITION
OF MEDICAL INFORMATION. AB
TWELVE FIFTY TWO WILL BRING
THESE TECHNOLOGIES AND THE
INFORMATION THEY COLLECT UNDER
C. M. I. A. BY CONSIDERING ANY
BUSINESS THAT OFFERS SUCH AN
APPLICATION OR DEVICE. TO A
CONSUMER TO BE A HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER. THIS WILL ENSURE THAT
SENSITIVE HEALTH DATA IS
TREATED WITH THE SAME CARE AS
DATA THAT IS GENERATED IN A
TRADITIONAL MEDICAL SETTING.
AND PROHIBIT THAT INFORMATION
FROM BEING SHARED WITH
OUTPATIENTS WRITTEN CONSENT-
WITHOUT AYE HEALTH CLUB MARIE
MAHONEY ON BEHALF OF CONSUMER
REPORTS- HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL MOVE
TO OUR- PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS MAUREEN MAHONEY POLICY
ANALYST AT CONSUMER REPORT. AND
WE'VE TAKEN A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION ON A. B.
TWELVE FIFTY TWO WHICH COULD
PROVIDE CRUCIAL PROTECTIONS FOR
CONSUMERS BY EXTENDING EXISTING
STRONG HEALTH PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS TO SENSITIVE
INFORMATION GENERATED BY NEW
FORMS OF HEALTH TECHNOLOGY. IN
CALIFORNIA PATIENT PRIVACY IS
PROTECTED BY THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF MEDICAL
INFORMATION ACT AND HIPAA
HOWEVER THESE TWO LAWS ONLY
PROTECT SENSITIVE HEALTH
INFORMATION IS GENERATED BY
CERTAIN ENTITIES. THE
INFORMATION CREATED BY NEW
HEALTH TECHNOLOGIES SUCH AS
DIGITAL HELP FEEDBACK SYSTEMS
AND ONLINE HEALTH SERVICES DO
NOT FALL INTO THIS RUBRIC. AND
ALTHOUGH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT WOULD
APPLY TO THE STATE OUT THAT WAS
NOT STRONG. FOR EXAMPLE THE
CITY PA ALLOWS CONSUMERS TO
STOP THE SALE OF THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION. BUT SEE MY A AND
HAVE PROPER MOST CASES THIS AT
ALL. AND CONSUMER BY. THAT C.
T. PAY OFF PROCESS. CAN
SOMETIMES BE SO- ONEROUS
THEY'VE HAD THE EFFECT OF
PREVENTING CONSUMERS FROM
STOPPING THE SALE OF THEIR
INFORMATION. HOWEVER WE DO
RECOMMEND SEVERAL CHANGES TO
THE BILL RESTRICTING THIS BILL
TO ONLY THE HEALTH TECHNOLOGY
THAT FDA APPROVED COULD CREATE.
A DISINCENTIVE FOR DEVELOPERS
TO GO THROUGH THE FDA APPROVAL
PROCESS BUT THE RECOMMEND
REMOVING LANGUAGE. LIMITING THE
BILL TO COVERING ONLY HEALTH
TECHNOLOGY THE FUSE AT THE
DIRECTION OF A PROVIDER OF
HEALTH CARE. WITH THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE OF COLLECTING THE
INDIVIDUAL'S INFORMATION IT IS
UNCLEAR HOW THOSE PROVISIONS
COULD WORK IN PRACTICE AND
COULD CREATE LOOPHOLES- WITH
ADJUSTMENTS THIS PROVISION
HOWEVER AB TWELVE FIFTY TWO
WOULD PROVIDE ESSENTIAL PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS. OF WORKING TO
SIMMER SENT TO THE DATA THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY. THANK YOU BEFORE
WE MOVE ON I'M GOING TO ASK OUR
WE HAVE LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A
QUORUM SOMEONE ASK OUR SIX US.
SECRETARY. TO CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. WHAT HERE. MAYES
AGUIAR-CURRY BIGELOW BONTA
BURKE CAREER. FLORA MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY. NAZARIAN RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO WALDRON. WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A QUORUM-
DO YOU HAVE A SECOND WITNESS MR
CHAU I DON'T BELIEVE SO OKAY
BEFORE WE GO ON TO ANY
POTENTIAL WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
I WOULD LIKE TO- ASKED WE PAUSE
ONE MORE MOMENT- IT WOULD LIKE
TO ASK FOR A MOTION AND A
SECOND TO ADOPT THE COMMITTEE
RULES SO WE COULD ACTUALLY
FUNCTION. SO- THE MOTION BY
MISS CARILLO OUR ISSUES MEMBERS
MY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND
BY MISS KOREA- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. TO ADOPT
COMMITTEE ROLES WHAT I WOULD
AYE MAYES. MAYES I AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW II BONTA. BURKE CARILLO.
CARILLO II FLORA FLORA I
MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY NAZARIAN
REVERSED RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO WALDRON WALDRON I. WE
HAVE A- WE HAVE EIGHT SO IT THE
COMMITTEE ROLES PASSED SO- ARE
THERE IS THERE A PRIMARY
WITNESS OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO AB. TWELVE
FIFTY TWO. SO WE HAVE NO
PRIMARY WITNESS TO TESTIFY
AGAINST. THE BILL THE CORRECT.
ASSUME IT'S CORRECT AT THIS
POINT. I WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF THE AUTHOR. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OF THE
AUTHOR. C. NINE WE WILL GO TO
THE PUBLIC LINES AND ASK FOR-
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT- OR
OPPOSITION AS YOU JUST GOING TO
ASK YOU TO STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL SO WITH THAT- TO OUR
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES AND CALL OUR FIRST-
CONTRIBUTOR. THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK ON AB TWELVE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD ONCE AGAIN THAT'S THE
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WELL THE
FIRST TIME LINE SEVENTY THREE
SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHEN NUMBER CATALINA SANCHEZ
THE CORPORATE ANTI THERE ON
BEHALF OF PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE AND ACLU
CALIFORNIA POLITICIAN IS NOT
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS THE R.
ANY SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION
AND WILL ALIGN COMMENTS THE
BILL'S OF CONSUMER REPORTS. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS OUR NEXT COMMON AS
LINE. THANK YOU LINE FIFTY SIX
FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE CALLING FROM
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER INDISPENSABLE AT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN YOUR
LINES OF. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
FIELDING GRIEVES OF THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ONE APOLOGIZED TO
THE COMMITTEE AND TO THE AUTHOR
FOR THE LATE OPPOSITION HERE I
ALSO POWER TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION- WE'RE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE TODAY BELIEVE THE
REGULATION IS PREMATURE AND
WITH FOR THAT THE FDA
DEPARTMENT OF. HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES ADDRESS THIS FEDERALLY
WITH A COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION
AFTER SOME EXTENSIVE RESEARCH-
THROUGH THE NATIONAL COMMITTEE
ON VITAL AND HEALTH STATISTICS
AND AGAIN AFTER SPECTRALLY- I
OPPOSED TODAY THANK YOU. OKAY I
REMIND CALLERS- DAT THIS THE
TIME IS TO SAY A SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AN ORGANIZATION ONLY
PLEASE SELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR NO MORE NO
FURTHER ALIGNED IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER CHARGE LIKE TO
CLOSE HI I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ARRIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY. IS THERE A MOTION. THE
MOTION BY MISTER AGUILAR CURRY
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO THE
MOTION WOULD BE DO PASS TO
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE. OF THE BILL DOES
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
BY THE CHAIR LOS MADAM
SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I WOULD I WOULD I MAYES
MAYES I AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING. BONTA BURKE
CARRILLO. CARRILLO I LARA FLOOR
NO MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY NAZARIAN
REVERSE RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO WALDRON. FIVE TO ONE
WHICH I WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR
NEXT BILL- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVIES AB THREE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB THREE EIGHT ONE I
WANT TO THANK COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WITH MY STAFF ON THIS
BILL AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. WHETHER
STATUS HAD TO DEAL WITH THE
GLOBAL HEALTH PANDEMICS I'M
LIKE WE'VE EVER SEEN BEFORE. IT
CANNOT BE LOST BUT WE HAVE A
CONTINUOUS HEALTH EPIDEMIC
SWEEPING OUR STATE. AS WELL AS
OUR COUNTRY OF COURSE I'M
TALKING ABOUT A BATTLE WITH
OPIOIDS. ACCORDING TO THE
CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL
THERE ARE OVER ONE THOUSAND
DRUG OVERDOSE DEATHS NATIONALLY
BETWEEN. MAY TWENTY NINETEEN
AND MAY TWENTY ONE MAKE OF THAT
AB ONE THOUSAND. IN THE LAST
YEAR THIS IS RISE BY 34% THOSE
ARE BETTING THEIR DICTION TO
THESE DRUGS ARE ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE VICTIMS. IN ORANGE
COUNTY WE HAVE HEARD OF DRUG
DEALERS SELLING NARCOTICS NEAR
GROUNDS A DRUG TREATMENT
FACILITIES OR WORSE MILLION
NARCOTICS TO THEM. TO HELP
COMBAT THIS EPIDEMIC ON MARCH
FIFTH TWENTY NINETEEN THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ISSUED
INFORMATIONNOTICE NINETEEN
DASH ZERO ZERO NINE. THE FIRM
ON NOTICE TECHNOLOG THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC IN AUTHORIZED DRUG
TREATMENT FACILITIES TO PROCESS
AND USED TO LACKS ON BETTER
KNOWN AS NOR CAN HOWEVER THIS
NOTICE DID NOT REQUIRE DRUG
TREATMENT FACILITIES TO
PURCHASE. DARKHAN AND HAVE A
STAFF MEMBER TRAINED IN
ADMINISTRATION ONSITE AT ALL
TIMES. AB THREE EIGHTY ONE IS A
SIMPLE MEASURE MEANT TO EXPAND
THAT FORMAL NOTICE BY REQUIRING
DRUG TREATMENT CENTERS TO
ACTUALLY CARRY AT LEAST TWO
DOSES OF DARKHAN. ON SITE PLUS
HAVE A STAFF MEMBER TRAINED HOW
TO ADMINISTER IT. THERE'S AN
ESTIMATED OVER TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND LIVES THAT HAVE BEEN
SAVED JUST BY HAVING THESE KIDS
WITHIN FAMILY HOMES. THE
CLOSING I BELIEVE THIS IS A
COMMON SENSEAPPROACH TO
LITERALLY HELP SAVE THE LIVES
OF A LIBERAL CLASS OF PEOPLE.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WITH ME HERE TODAY VIA
PHONE IS JOHN TO PROCEED WITH
THE SAN DIEGO DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OFFICE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
SHANTI FRESH AND I'M A
PROSECUTOR THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
WHERE I SERVE AS THE ASSISTANT
CHIEF OF OUR MAJOR NARCOTICS
DIVISION. I'M HERE TODAY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE EIGHTY ONE ONE OF OUR
AREAS OF FOCUS IS THE
PROTECTION OF CHEMICALLY
DEPENDENT NARCOTICS USERS WHO
ARE INJURED BECAUSE THE INFLUX
OF DANGEROUS OPIOIDS INCLUDING
FENTANYL WHICH IS FIFTY TO ONE
HUNDRED TIMES MORE POTENT THAN
MORPHINE. DEATHS ARE
SKYROCKETING IN OUR NATION
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS CURRENT
PANDEMIC ONE OF THE TROUBLING
TRENDS WE'VE SEEN STATEWIDE
INVOLVED THE RISE OF OVERDOSES
AND DRUG TREATMENT CENTERS.
SINCE RECEIVING TREATMENT AT
THE CENTERS FIND WAYS TO ACCESS
HOPE YOU IS. THE RISK OF
OVERDOSE IS ESPECIALLY HIGH
WITHIN THESE FACILITIES SINCE
PATIENT DRUG TOLERANCE
DECREASES AFTER PERIODS OF
SOBRIETY. THIS DEADLY RISK IS
COMPOUNDED BY THE FACT THAT
CENTRAL QUIETLY CONTAMINATE THE
ILLICIT DRUG SUPPLY. MOST
COMMONLY USERS ARE KILLED BY
COUNTERFEIT OXY CODE ON PILLS
THAT FORENSICALLY TESTED AS
PURE FENTANYL. NALOXONE ALSO
KNOWN AS NOR CAN. IT EFFECTIVE
DRUG THAT REVERSES THE EFFECTS
OF AN OPIOID OVERDOSE. QUITE
SIMPLY IT SAVES LIVES WITH A
SIMPLE SQUARE IN THE NOSE. THE
VERY FIRST OPIOID OVERDOSE
MITIGATION MEASURES SUGGESTED
BY OUR CDC. THE TO QUOTE EXPAND
DISTRIBUTION AND USE OF
NALOXONE AN OVERDOSE PREVENTION
EDUCATION AND QUOTE. WE KNOW
THAT TO BE TRUE. BECAUSE
RECENTLY A POLICE OFFICER IN
OUR COUNTY WAS SAVED BY
NALOXONE AFTER AN ACCIDENTAL
FENTANYL EXPOSURE THAT
OCCURRED. DURING THE HANDLING
OF DRUG EVIDENCE. EIGHT SUCH AS
KINETIC MESSAGE WISCONSIN AND
NEW MEXICO. HAVE REQUIRED TO
WALK DON'T ACCESS TO POTABLE
PATIENTS. WE SHOULD BE DOING
THE SAME BY REQUIRING THE DRUG
TREATMENT CENTERS THE DEATH TO
UNEXPIRED DOSES OF NALOXONE SO
THEY CAN EFFECTIVELY TREAT
THEIR MOST VULNERABLE PATIENTS
ON THE VERGE OF DEATH. AB THREE
EIGHTY ONE WILL SAVE LIVES.
BECAUSE OF THAT I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY. ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN AS THEY'RE IN
THERE HE SAID THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION- SO THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION WITNESS THAT YOU'RE
AWARE OF THAT. OKAY BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COULD MISTER
RODRIGUEZ. THEY WERE BEING
ASKED WE'RE ASKING YOU TO STAND
WHEN YOU TALK IF YOU DON'T MIND.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIR. THANK YOU SOMEONE FOR
BRING THE BILL FORD MELANCTHON
IS A VERY LIFESAVING DRUGS
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THIS ISSUE
IN OUR RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES.
I JUST HAD A QUICK QUESTION
TALKED ABOUT. UNEXPIRED DESERT
ISSUE WITH THESE FACILITIES
HAVE BEEN EXPIRED MEDICATIONS
AS WELL AS THE REASON WHY WE
JUST MAKE SURE IT'S INCLUDED
THAT. IT IS NOT AN EXPIRED- DOT
TWO DOSES OF NALOXONE. NOT THAT
I KNOW OF- MISTER TO FRESHLY.
NO THERE'S NO- PRESSING ISSUE
WE JUST KNOW THAT THEY CAN
EXPIRE SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS ADVOCACY TO THE
NALOXONE THAT ACTUALLY EXISTS
WITHIN THE CENTERS. OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH- WILL BE A VOTE IN
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AS WELL SO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BURDENS BUT
A BILL FOR THANK YOU. MISTER
MISTER BIGELOW. NO OKAY.
ANYBODY ANYBODY ELSE. I JUST
LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU FOR BRING
THE BILL FORWARD AND- IT'S I'M
SORT OF SURPRISED THAT WE'RE IN
A POINT WHERE WE HAVE TO ASK
FOR THIS BUT WE OBVIOUSLY DO
AND- SO I APPRECIATE THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING I KNOW WHEN I WAS
PRACTICING YOU KNOW I WOULD GO
THROUGH AND PUT THE QUESTION TO
MISTER RIGHT RODRIGUEZ BROUGHT
UP ABOUT SPIDERS THAT EXPIRED I
HAD A CRASH KIT WENT THROUGH
MADE ROUTINELY WENT THROUGH
THERE TO MAKE SURE EVERYTHING
WAS. NOT EXPIRED- AND BECAUSE
THESE ARE THESE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT MEDICATIONS BUT YOU
KNOW UNFORTUNATELY WE WOULD
SOMETIMES GO SPELL THAT OUT FOR
PEOPLE MAKE IT MAKE IT REALLY
CLEAR SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THAT FORWARD WE'LL ASK THE-
OPERATOR TO OPEN THE PHONE
LINES THESE SO WE ARE JUST PER
REFRESH PEOPLE WE'RE BLENDING
RIZZA SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION SO
AT THIS POINT WE'RE JUST ASKING
YOU STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL AND NO NO FURTHER
TESTIMONY THAN THAT. SO PLEASE
GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE PHONE
LINES. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO. SPEAK TOWARDS EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE ME PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. THAT'S
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. LOCAL
FIRST TIMELINE OF SEVENTY TWO
SEVEN TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHANGE ROCK
DESPITE ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE IN A SUPPORTIVE MENDED ON
THIS BILL AND WE'VE INCLUDED.
ARE THE QUESTION I'M IN A
POSITION MATTER THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. THE CALLER
PLEASE. THE CONCERN LINE SIXTY
SIX SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE GIVEN
BUT THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT CALL
THANK YOU KNOW OTHER LINES IN
CUBA AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD
THANK YOU. GET BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE WE HAD A MOTION BY
MISHECK AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND
BY MR BIGELOW- THE MOTION AND
THE MOTION WELL. I SHOULD STOP
APOLOGIZES OUR FIRST HEARING OF
THE EAR OF THE ROOM LOW RUSTY
HERE WHICH I TO CLOSE- IS
DAVIES. I JUST ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I AND I THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND- THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHEN I WOULD I MAYES. MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. BIGELOW BIGELOW
II BONTA. BURKE BURKE I CARILLO
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA I
MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY THIS AREA
RIVAS RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO WALDRON
WALDRON I. NINE ZERO YOUR BILL
HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT OF
COMMITTEE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AT THIS POINT LIKE TO GO
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR- I'M
LOOKING FOR A MOTION FOR THE
CONSECUTIVE MUCH MINUS CARILLO
SECOND BY MISS WALDRON. FOR
CLARIFICATION OF ON THE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR INCLUDES- ITEM
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
ONE BERMAN ITEM NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY EIGHT CALLED
AROUND ITEM NUMBER SIX A. B.
ELEVEN TWELVE OR ONE TWELVE- MR
HOLDEN I'M NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY TWO- CENTER COM
LONGER ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWO
THIRTY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS I'VE NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORA AND NUMBER. FOURTEEN
NUMBER SIXTEEN AB SIX SEVENTY
FOUR ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
AND ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE A HEALTH
COMMITTEE BILL SO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WOULD I
WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. BIGELOW. BIGELOW
II BONTA BURKE BURKE I CARILLO-
I FLORA LARA AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY NAZARIAN RIVAS. RIVAS
III RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON I.
NINE ZERO. SECKAU UNDERPASSES
AND LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON MISTER GIBSON
SHE GIPSON HAS AB. THREE FORTY
TWO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY TWO-
THIS LET ME POINT OUT A FEW
THINGS OF REGARDING THIS
PARTICULAR VEIL- THIS BILL WILL
ELIMINATE THE COST FOR PATIENTS
WHO NEED A COLONOSCOPY IS AFTER
A POSITIVE TAKE HOME TEST AND-
PROMOTE- EARLY DETECTION FOR
COLON CANCER. BY LETTING
PATIENTS- SCREEN THEMSELVES
SAFELY AT HOME COLORECTAL
CANCER IS THE SECOND HIGHEST
CAUSE OF CANCER DEATH IN THE IN
THE UNITED STATES AND THE THIRD
MOST COMMON CANCER IN MEN AND
WOMEN. HOWEVER THIS CANCER IS
THE MOST PREVENTABLE WITH
SCREENING AND EARLY DETECTION
TIMELY SCREENING CAN REDUCE THE
CANCER MORTALITY BY UP 2660%
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
REQUIRES INSURANCE TO COVER
PREVENTATIVE SCREENING TESTS
WITHOUT COST SHARING HOWEVER.
MANY HEALTH PLANS CHARGED FOR
THE FOLLOW UP EXAMINATION
BECAUSE ONLY THE FIRST TASK IS
CONSIDERED PREVENTIVE
PREVENTIVE- THE AVERAGE COST OF
THE FOLLOW UP COLONOSCOPY IS
ABOUT FOURTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THIS IS A VERY FOR SENIORS LOW
INCOME PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR WHO CANNOT AFFORD TO
FOURTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS THEY
NEED LEAVING THEM AT HIGH RISK
OF A PREVENTABLE DEATH. MY BILL
CHANGES CURRENT LAW BY
PROHIBITING HEALTH PLANS IN
CALIFORNIA FROM FOR RECORD
CARVING COST SHARING ON
SCREENINGS AND LAB TESTS FOR
ANYONE AT HIGH RISK FOR COLO
RECTAL CANCER. WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS
BOTTOM- NUMBER. THE ADDAMS
HOLDEN WITH THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY AND ALSO A DOCTOR STONE
WALL ANDERSON FOR C. FOR. WHO
WILL TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL
OPEN IT UP FOR OUR PRIMARY
SUPPORT ME WITNESSES. RMB YOU
WANT ME TO GO. YEAH THANK YOU
YEAH- GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TO
YOU ABOUT AB THREE FORTY TWO.
I'M DOCTOR DANIEL STONE WALL
ANDERSON PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
COLORECTAL CANCER COALITION THE
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
IN 202-115-0008 HUNDRED EIGHTY
CALIFORNIA IS EXPECTED TO
DEVELOP COLON CANCER AND FIVE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED NINETY
CALIFORNIANS ARE EXPECTED TO
DIE FROM COLON CANCER. THIS IS
A TRAGEDY SINCE COLON CANCER
HAS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
SCREENING TESTS OF ALL CANCER
SCREENING TEST. ON SCREEN YOU
HAVE A SIX POINT 7% CHANCE OF
GETTING COLON CANCER. ONE IN
EVERY FIFTEEN ON SCREEN PEOPLE
GET COLON CANCER LIKE GROWTH
THE SIZE OF YOUR COMMITTEE. YOU
CAN EXPECT ONE PERSON DEVELOP
COLON CANCER. ONE IN THIRTY
FIVE ON SCREEN PEOPLE WOULD DIE
OF COLON CANCER WITH SCREENING
COLON CANCERS ARE PREVENTABLE
BY REMOVING POLICY. CANCERS ARE
FOUNDED EARLY TREATABLE STAGE
AND WITH SURGERY. THE COLON
CANCERS SECURE. AS A RIP IN THE
U. S. FOR A SERVICE GOT
SCREENING. IN A DROP IN THE
DEATH RATE FROM. TWO POINT 8%
TO ZERO POINT 5% THIS MEANS
THAT IN THE SCREEN POPULATION
INSTEAD OF ONE AND- THIRTY FIVE
DYING OF COLON CANCER IT'S ONE
AND TWO HUNDRED MORE SIMPLY WE
HAVE TO SCREEN. FIFTY PEOPLE TO
PREVENT ONE PERSON FROM DYING
FROM COLON CANCER. IN SPITE OF
THIS AN INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE
SCREENING. THROUGH EITHER-
FECAL TEST DONE AT HOME OR
COLONOSCOPY EVERY TEN YEARS
ONLY 72% OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
BEEN SCREENED. WHY ARE SO MANY
AND SCREENED. YOU HAVE TO OFFER
BOTH THE HOME TESTING AND THE
COLONOSCOPY. AND WE KNOW THAT
IT TESTING PLACES INCREASE
FINANCIAL BURDENS ON OUR
PATIENTS. ABOUT KAISER PERMAN
SAY THEY STARTED THEIR MAIL OUT
SCREENING PROGRAM INCREASE
COLORECTAL CANCER SCREENING
THEY MADE SURE THEY DID NOT
CHARGE A COPAY FOR THE
COLONOSCOPY AFTER A POSITIVE IT
BY OFFERING BOTH COLONOSCOPY
AND FIT TESTING. THEY EXCEEDED
80% SCREENING AND LOWER
COLORECTAL CANCER INCIDENCE BY
25% AND WITH CORRECT- CANCER
MORTALITY BY 52% THE BILL
ENCOURAGING FIT TESTING COULD
MICHAEL REICHEL CANCER
SCREENING CALL STAVING. MODEL
BASED STUDIES HAVE FOUND THAT
COLORECTAL CANCER SCREENING
USING HOME FECAL TESTING CAN
RESULT IN COST SAVING IN THE
LONG RUN BECAUSE OF THE RISING
COST OF COLON CANCER CARE. THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
DECREASED COLORECTAL CANCER
SCREENING RATES BY LIMITING
ACCESS TO SCREENING
COLONOSCOPIES HOWEVER CLINICS
THEY WROTE RELY ON MAILED OUT
DONE HOME FIFTY S. THING HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO MAINTAIN THEIR
SCREENING RATES. AS REPORTED BY
PARK STREET COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTER A CALIFORNIA FEDERAL
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER. BY
VOTING FOR THIS BILL YOU AN
COLORECTAL CANCER SCREENING
RATES AND SAVE LIVES. WITH
INCREASED USE OF IT AS WE CAN
PUT MONEY BACK INTO OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE REQUESTING
YOUR YES VOTE ON THIS BILL HELP
US SAVE LIVES. AND REDUCE
SUFFERING FROM COLON CANCER
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS AUTUMN OGDEN. AND
CERAMIC I THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. AUTOMATICALLY MEANT
WITH THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY CANCER ACTION NETWORK
WHICH PROUD TO SPONSOR AN.
EIGHTY THREE FORTY TWO. TIMELY
AND APPROPRIATE SCREENING CAN
DECREASE COLORECTAL CANCER
INCIDENCE AND MORTALITY BY UP
TO THIRTY TO SIXTY PERCENT. AN
INSURED AND UNDER INSURED ARE
LEAST LIKELY TO GET GREEN AND
MOST LIKELY TO BE DIAGNOSED AT
A LATE STAGE FOR SURVIVAL RATE
DROPPED TO THIRTEEN PERCENT.
BOB CORKER CANCER INCIDENCE OF
DECREASED AMONG ALL MORE FOR
ALL FOUR MAJOR RACIAL ETHNIC
GROUPS WHICH SCREENING RATES
AMONG THOSE IN POVERTY AND
AMONG HISPANICS STILL REMAIN
LOW. HEALTH PLAN REQUIRE P. TO
OUT. COSTS FOR THE FOLLOW UP
CALL. WHICH CAN BE A BARRIER TO
MANY PATIENTS COMPLETING
MCCORKLE CANCER SCREENING.
ADDITIONALLY RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT LIMITING CALL OUR COMPUTER
SCREENS RIGHT THAT THE ONLY A
COLONOSCOPY TO RESULT IN. A
LOWER COURT TO CANCER SCREENING
COMPLETION RATE COMPARED TO
PROVIDING A CHOICE. BETWEEN
COLONOSCOPY AND GOLDIE TAX.
PARTICULARLY AMONG RACIAL AND
ETHNIC NINE ONE MINORITY. I'M
LIMITING OUT OF POCKET COST
SHARING THE BALL GOING. AFTER A
POSITIVE STILL AT. WILLIMON A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO CORKER
CANCER SCREENING I DON'T THINK
MANY LIVES. FOR THESE REASONS
WE ASK AYE THOSE TODAY ON.
EIGHTY THREE FORTY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IS THE
THERE ANY- PRIMARY WITNESSES
OFFICE. REGISTERED WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. NINE NINE HEARING
OF ANY- BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. COMMENTS C. NINE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
GIBSON JUST THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE FOR HEARING THIS BILL
REALIZES A PRIVILEGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I VOTE.
WITH THAT WILL GO TO THE WE'LL
GO TO THE PRIMARY LINES AND MY
APOLOGIES I. JUMP THE GUN ON
THAT BUT- STILL RUSTY HERE I GO
TO THE LINES AND ASKING FOR-
THE CALLERS TO- IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL JUST
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
SO- STRUCK GREATER PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND OPEN THE LINES. THANK
YOU TO SHARE YOUR OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FORTY TO ME
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. IN
MASS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MOGULDOM LINE NUMBER
SIXTY FIVE SIX FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO ANDREA TERRY PUT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCE ASSOCIATION BOARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU TURN OVER THE
LINE SECURE AT THIS TIME OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
WE HAVE A WILL CLOSE FROM
MISTER MISTER GIPSON- WE HAVE A
MOTION- LOOKING FOR US A SECOND
FROM BY MR MAYES A SECOND FROM
THIS CARILLO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- ARE YOU
ACCEPTING OR AMENDMENTS MISTER
GIPSON YES. MISTER MISTER
GIBSON'S EXCEPT IN THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- WITH THAT
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
ROLE IN ASKED THE SECTOR TO-
CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE
MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY. BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE BURKE I CARILLO. HI
LAURA FLOOR AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY
NAZARIAN REQUEST. RIVAS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ HI SANTIAGO
WALDRON MAYES MAYES I. IT'S.
EIGHT ZERO. EIGHT ZERO SO THE
BILL PASSES- BILLS OUT OF
COMMITTEE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS THAT ON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR GIPSON. OUR
NEXT AUTHOR. PETRIE-NORRIS
EITHER YOU ARE. IT'S FAR BACK%
THERE IT'S HARD TO SEE HIDING
IN THE BACKGROUND. YOU HAVE AB
TWO SIXTY FIVE. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. AB. TWO SIXTY
FIVE EIGHTY TWO SIXTY FIVE WILL
REMOVE THE 80% OF MEDICARE CAP
ON MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FOR CALIFORNIA LAST. THIS WILL
MAINTAIN A ROBUST LABORATORY
FORCED TO PROVIDE COULD
NINETEEN TESTING AND OTHER
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH TESTING
WILL ENSURE THAT LABS CAN
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
TESTING SERVICES FOR MEDICAL
PATIENTS WILL ALSO KEEP HIGH
PAYING JOBS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M BY WAY OF A BIT OF
BACKGROUND CONGRESSIONAL ACTION
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN ATTENDED THE
INTENT OF CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY
TWELVE BUDGET ACT WHICH
MAINTAINED A CALIFORNIA MARKET
BASED METHOD TO DETERMINE THE
FEE FOR SERVICE MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR LAB
SERVICES. THE RESULTS AT THE OF
THESE- FEDERAL CHANGES IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN HAS LEFT
LABORATORY SERVICES UNDER
WATER. AND THAT BY REMOVING THE
CAP CALIFORNIA LABS WILL BE
WILL BE ABLE TO ONCE AGAIN
OPERATE HOW THE STATE
ORIGINALLY INTENDED THEM TO DO
SO IT'S ALSO WORTH NOTING THAT
THE CURRENT POLICY
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS.
SAFETY NET PROVIDERS AND SMALL
LABORATORIES SUCH AS PLANNED
PARENTHOOD BOB THIS BILL WILL
PROTECT MEDICARE PATIENTS
ACROSS THE STATE AND THAT KEEP
GOOD PAYING JOBS HEREIN
CALIFORNIA LAST. PLEASED TO BE
JOINED TODAY BY REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CLINICAL
LAB ASSOCIATION AND TO FIVE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
OF CALIFORNIA YOU ARE JOINING
US TO TESTIFY. AND ANSWER. ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOVE
TO OUR WILL. YOU CAN OPEN THE
LINES WHENEVER. THEY'RE
AVAILABLE. AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
OKAY GREAT SORRY AND THIS IS MY
BROKEN LEG PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AT BILLION TE CALIFORNIA AND
WE ARE PROBABLY SUPPORTING AB
pFAMILY MEMBERS BAD WILL REMOVE
THAT 80% OF MEDICARE CAP
ALLOWED. REIMBURSEMENT RATE IN
MEDICARE. NOW PERCENT OF
PARENTHOOD PATIENTS AND HEALTH
AREN'T AND FAMILY PACKAGE THAT.
OUTSIDE OUR HEALTH THEY DID
BEFORE. AFFECTED BY THE CURRENT
B. OF MEDICARE FROM MEDIC HOW
OPERATE. RIGHT AND EFFECTIVE.
BECAUSE BY THE MEDICARE CAP
UNDERMINE ABOUT MADE A MEDIC
CAL LIKE THAT BE A PROPERTY.
BECAUSE THE PROPERTY SIX
PLANNED PARENTHOOD- AFFILIATES
ARE ABLE TO INCREASE APPETITE
ACTING BY ABOUT 10220% OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS. OTHER THOUGHT
THE STI ADAMEK AND WRITING SO
THAT OUR HEALTH CENTERS FROM
PROVIDING ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION HAD ANNUALLY FOR
GONORRHEA CHLAMYDIA SYPHILIS
AND HIV SPECIFICALLY. TO THE MY
ACCOUNT POPULATION. IT HAD
PROVIDED THE LAB. IN HOUSE
WHICH ALLOWS US. TO FEED. OUR
CURRENT ALLOW THE FOR PATIENTS
TO A CLINICIAN. WITH THE FACT
AND A ALL IN ONE. AND OFTEN A
SINGLE DAY. I MEAN THREE
CUTBACKS I'D HAVE TO CUT BY MY
CAP THAT DOCTOR ON THE FRONT
LINES BATCH I DON'T MAKE
ESPECIALLY WHEN I TYPING IN
DOWN ACROSS THE STATE KOBE. WE
KNOW ONE PUBLIC HEALTH ADDED
THERE BE AN IN NEED FOR AT TAX
UNDERSTAND THE EXACT TO WHICH I
THE AT THE- OKAY TO THE BACK OF
THE P. AND LOOK. TO BE IN ON
PRIOR FOR THE DAY. THE CURRENT
MEMBER THE MEMBERS BUT NOT ALL
G. PUTS US WORKING AND
EVENTUALLY FIVE A CRITICAL
QUARTER THE FAMED ACT DURING
THE I AM NOT I CANNOT. CAN
FURTHER IN PUBLIC IS AND IN ARE
YOU FACING MANY HEALTH. THIRTY
THREE THE RESPECT URGE I LOVE
AND IN THE BOTH PRETTY. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. GOOD AFTER
THIS IS CHRIS BOY. I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE HELP CLINICAL
ASSOCIATES IN STRONG OF AB TWO
SIXTY. WE AS MEMBERS OF OUR
THIRTY. SAN LARGE LEVERAGE SUCH
AS QUEST LAP. HOSPITAL
LABORATORY DISAPPEARED.
ACADEMIC GLAD THANK YOU SEE
DAVID AND MANY OTHER SMALLER
INNOVATIVE INDEPENDENT
LABORATORIES SUCH AS VERIFYING
THAT SPECIALIZES IN TESTING
RELATED TO THYROID CANCER LUNG
CANCER AND BREAST CANCER. THIS
BILL IS NECESSARY TO ONE THIRTY
EQUITABLE AND SUSTAINABLE
PAYMENT RATE IN MEDIC
CALIFORNIA CLINICAL LABORATORY
DIAGNOSTIC TESTS. IN TO HELP
MAINTAIN ACCESS TO ALL OF THE
TESTING FOR MEDIC CAL PATIENT.
EIGHTY TWO SIXTY FIVE IS NEEDED
TO UPDATE MEDIC HELP PRICING
REQUIREMENTS FOR LAB TESTS TO
REFLECT THE NEW MEDICARE
PAYMENT SYSTEM. LAVATORY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SUCH AS
THE ONES I MENTIONED HAVE BEEN
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK AND
UNDER CONSIDERABLE STRAIN AS
THEY TRIED TO SUPPORT OUR STATE
FOR BONTA CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE PERCENT CUT ARM
FORWARD I WANT THE MOST
CHALLENGING TIME FOR CLINICAL
LABORATORIES IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS A WELL
DEVELOPED PAYMENT SYSTEM IN
PLACE TO SET OUR CALIFORNIA
RIGHT. NOW IS NOT THE TIME FOR
NEW CUTS TRIGGERED BY AN OLD
AUTOMATIC TIED TO A PRIOR
VERSION OF THE MEDICARE PAYMENT
SYSTEM. FOR ALL THESE REASONS
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU I'M
AVAILABLE QUESTIONS ALSO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I DON'T BELIEVE
ARE THERE ANY REGISTERED
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE ARE. NOT HEARING
TOO MANY WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ACTUALLY I HAVE A I HAVE A
QUESTION AND THAT'S WHAT I KNOW
THAT. ERICA RATES ARE ARE LOW-
AND NOBODY WANTS TO SEE THEM
REDUCED IN ANYWAY SO I GUESS
THE QUESTION I HAVE- IS THERE
IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE THT THE
CURRENT METHODOLOGY HAS CREATED
AN ACCESS PROBLEM SO I GUESS
WHAT I'M ASKING FOR IS- ARE THE
NUMBER OF LABS DECLARE-
DECLINING MEDICARE BUSINESS. OR
LIMITING THEIR PARTICIPATION IN
THE PROGRAM. WELL INSTRUMENT
THE AT THE CUTS THAT HAVE BEEN
TRIGGERED BY THE FEDERAL
CHANGES ARE YET TO BE
IMPLEMENTED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SO. THE GOAL FOR THIS BILL IS
TO TAKE ACTION BEFORE THOSE AT
WE SEE THAT DECREASING ACCESS
WHICH- WE DO EXPECT AND I THINK
OUR WITNESSES MAY HAVE SOME
COMMENTS. WE DO EXPECT THAT IF
THESE CHANGES ARE TRIGGERED IF
WE SEE LABORATORY REIMBURSEMENT
RATES THAT ARE EFFECTIVELY. B.
BELOW THE COST OF PROVIDING A
SERVICE WE WILL SEE
LABORATORIES ACTUALLY MOVE OUT
OF CALIFORNIA WILL ALSO SEE A
LABORATORY CAPACITY AND ACCESS
REDUCED IN CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE
TRYING TO GET GET OUT AHEAD OF
THAT BY. IMPLEMENTING THIS
NECKLACE RATIONALIZATION NOW
I'M DO I EITHER OF OUR
WITNESSES WHEN IT. BUILT ON
THAT. RIGHT THE MONEY FROM
PLANNED PARENTHOOD I'LL JUST
ADD YOU KNOW BERKELEY
PARENTHOOD WILL NEVER CLOSE OUR
DOORS TO MEDICAL PATIENTS AS I
MENTIONED YOU KNOW THAT IS WHO
WE SERVE- BUT IT DOES TO BE
REALLY IMPACT HOW WE DO
BUSINESS HAVING. METRO ACTIVE
CLAWBACKS AND RATE REDUCTIONS-
WHICH WE'VE SEEN FAN. THAT
POLICY WENT INTO PLACE- OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS- IT MAKES IT
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR US TO MEET
OUR YEARLY BUDGET- WORKING AT
YEARS TO MONTHS TWO YEARS AFTER
PAYMENTS ALREADY BEEN PAID. AND
THEN BACK ARE THEN TAKEN BACK
BY THE DEPARTMENT- BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE A DRIVER'S PAYER MIX
TO LEAN ON HAVING MENTIONED 90%
OF OUR PATIENTS ARE MEDICARE
PATIENTS. IT JUST MAKES IT
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR US TO
MAINTAIN OUR. OUR HELP CENTER
FINALLY. OKAY THANK YOU. SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD AT THIS POINT-
AND BRING BACK TO THE THERE'S
GETTING ARE FROM ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I GUESS
THIRTY DID THAT OKAY SO WILL
OPEN UP PHONE LINES UP TO-
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION THIS WILL
BE JUST YOUR NAME AND POSITION
ONLY ON THE BILLSO. OPERATOR
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
LINES. YOU TO STATE YOUR
POSITION ON AB WHO SIX FIVE NEW
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD IN THE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. FOR THE
FIRST TIME LINE NINETY TWO NINE
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH HI
THIS IS MIKE ROBESON ON BEHALF
OF QUEST DIAGNOSTICS. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
THAT'S NINE NINETY NINE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI SHANNON
OLIVIERI HOPE THAT FROM
HAPPENING AROUND BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANKS CALLER. ON THE LINE
NINETY ONE NINE ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS WILLIAM
ATCHISON BURKE ON BEHALF OF
THAT THE CALIFORNIA NURSE
MIDWIFE ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER. MISTER
CHAIR NOT FOR THE LINES INTO IT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHICH I CLOSE. ASSEMBLY CLOSE
BY I RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR
YOUR ADDRESS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE HAD A WE HAVE
A MOTION. MOTION BY MISTER
MCCARTY SECOND BY MISS CARILLO-
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WEST MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT HI WHAT I MAYES MAYES I
FIGURE CURRY. BIGELOW. BONTA
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO. CARILLO
II FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE NAZARIAN RIVAS RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ SIZE
SANTIAGO WALDRON. NINE ZERO
BILL PASSES NINE ZERO LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER STAFF THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU. SO
WE'RE GOING NOW TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- MISS CARILLO AB. FIVE
SEVENTY THREE. TEST THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU- I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB FIVE SEVEN
THREE WHICH PROVIDES AN
UNREALIZED OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE IN ELEVATE YOUTH IN THE
COMMUNITY PLANNING PROCESS FOR
YOU SPECIFIC MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH BOARD AND
REQUIRES EACH COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE TO HAVE A LOCAL
YOUTH ADVISORY BOARD. THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF YOUNG PEOPLE
HAS ALWAYS BEEN A MAJOR PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERN THAT HAS BECOME
EVEN MORE PRESENT MORE PRESENT
AT THE WELL COVERED NINETEEN
THE PANDEMIC HAS FOR STUDENTS
STATE WIDE INTO REMOTE LEARNING
WHICH HAS DEEPENED THE STUDENT
HELP THE STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS AND NOT ALSO MADE IT
LESS VISIBLE TO SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES. CALIFORNIA IS HOME
TO SIX POINT TWO MILLION
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN K. THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS BETWEEN SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND OF
THEM UP TO ONE MILLION ARE
ESTIMATED TO HAVE A MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITION THIS IS ONLY
INTENSIFIED BY THE FACT THAT
ABOUT HALF TO THREE QUARTERS OF
YOU TO NOT RECEIVE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT OR SERVICES
AND UNFORTUNATELY SUFFER IN
SILENCE. YOUNG PEOPLE ARE NO
LONGER I'M SORRY YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE LONG OVERDUE FOR A SEAT AT
THE TABLE WHERE THEY CAN BETTER
ADVOCATE FOR QUALITY EFFECTIVE
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS IN WAYS
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THEY
THEMSELVES ARE ADVOCATING FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
SEEK HELP AND SPEAK FREELY
WITHOUT FEELING INSECURE
OVERSHADOWED AND IN ORDER TO
UNEQUIVOCALLY COMPREHEND THEIR
EXPERIENCES OF TRIBULATIONS.
YOUTH VOICES MUST AND SHOULD BE
INCLUDED IN THESE CONVERSATIONS
MEMBERS I SERVE ON THE ASSEMBLY
AS THE ASSEMBLY APPOINTEE OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN IN OFFICE
WE HAVE CONVENE GROUPS WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE TO LISTEN TO THEIR
CONCERNS AND HAVE HEARD TIME
AND TIME AGAIN HEALTH STRESS
THEY ARE. HOW THEY LIVE IN FEAR
OF A SCHOOL SHOOTING A SHOOTING
AT A MOVIE THEATER A SHOOTING
AT A CONCERT VENUE OR SHOOTING
AT A GROCERY STORE THEY SHARE
THAT THEY ARE SCARED OVER THEIR
PARENTS. LOSING THEIR JOBS NOT
BEING ABLE TO PAY THE AND- THEY
FEEL POWERLESS WALKING OVER ON
HOUSE NEIGHBORS ON THEIR WAY TO
SCHOOL SEEN THE STATE'S
HOMELESSNESS PRICES CONTINUE TO
RISE AND ULTIMATELY FEELING
DEPRESSED ALONE AND LIKE THEIR
PERSONAL LIVES DON'T MATCH THE
FALSE REALITIES OF SOCIAL MEDIA
MEMBERS THE STIGMA ASSOCIATED
WITH MENTAL HEALTH IS REAL IT
IS DETRIMENTAL TO ADULTS AND IT
ONLY IS INTENSIFIED AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO LACK ACCESS TO
SERVICES WE CAN CHANGE THAT
CREATING THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH BOARD IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
ON THIS BILL. AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD- ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY IS MATTHEW DEEP WITH
THE CENTER FOR PACIFIC ASIAN
FAMILY AND KARINA PAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. YOUR WITNESSES.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL I. RIGHT THE COULD NOT USE
THAT MY TIME AT THE- THANK YOU.
OKAY GO AHEAD EVERYONE MY NAME
MATTHEW I THIRD ON THE YOUTH
INNOVATION PROJECT PLANNING
COMMITTEE- AND I'M ALSO THE
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
SPIKE FOR A NONPROFIT BASED IN
L. A. COUNTY THAT IS- LED BY A
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF ALL
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH AND WE
THIRTEEN BEEN TRANSITIONAL AGE
YOUTH WELCOME THE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER AT ANSWER FOR THE
PACIFIC ASIAN FAMILY HELPING
YOU TO IDENTIFY APPOINT THE
VIOLENCE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND DEVELOPING PROPOSALS FOR
HOW WE CAN HELP AND VIOLENT- SO
I HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH YOU TO
HELP EMPOWER THEM TO. IDENTIFY
WE THE. TO PROMOTE COMMUNITY
WELLNESS- I AM MY ALONG WITH
NEXT. COULD OUR MENTAL- IN HOW-
I AM A TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD
CLEAR GIVE ME THE MERICAN MAN-
I AM THE CHILD OF REFUGEES AND
HAVE TO NAVIGATE GROWING UP.
I'M WITH INTERGENERATIONAL
TRAUMA AND NOT HAVING TO DEAL
WITH MY IDENTITY NEITHER IN MY
HOUSEHOLD WHEN THE SCHOOLS. AND
I BRING THAT UP BECAUSE-
NAVIGATING THE INTERSECTION WAS
A BIG CHALLENGE AND BY EIGHT A
LOT OF MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES- INDIVIDUALLY BUT
ALSO AS WELL AS IN THE SCHOOL
SETTING- AND I WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. SOME OF THE
NEXT OPPORTUNITY THERE WITHIN
THE SCHOOL- RATHER THAN LOOKING
AT. THE WAY OF EXPRESSING MY
NEEDS AND NOT GOING TO CLASS AT
THE CALL FOR HELP IN A WAY TO
COURTNEY. FONG POLICE WERE SENT
TO MY HOME TO FORTY TO GO TO
CLASS I WAS CONSTANTLY GETTING
PUNISHED. BOND FUTURES WERE
GETTING UPSET AT ME MAKING
CORPS VERY UNFAIR. WAIT FOR ME
TO BE A AND SO NATURALLY I
CONTINUE TO STEP AWAY FROM
SCHOOL- I WAS GIVEN AN
ULTIMATUM TO GO TO THERAPY- AND
FIVE FOUR THINK THAT THERE IS I
DIDN'T WANT TO BE AT THAT
WASN'T VERY HELPFUL AT ALL. ON
THE I WAS NOT INFORMED ABOUT
HEALTHCARE IF YOU COULD HELP ME
AND PUT IN LIKE A VERY SCARY
I'M RESOURCE AND AS I POINTED
THIS REPORT I CONTINUE TO BE
HARASSED BY MY SCHOOL. HI FOR
THE BENCHLEY ON DEALING WITH MY
DEPRESSION THROUGH SELF. HARM
AND- WELCOME ENDED UP IN OUR
FIFTY FIFTY. ONE INPATIENT
HOSPICE CARE. ON THE WAY HAPPEN
WITH MY AND HEALTH CRISIS CALL
DOWN MY DOOR. IN HAND. AND
CALLED ME OUT ON IT IN OF IN
BROAD DAYLIGHT AND MY ENTIRE
NEIGHBORHOOD WITH WATCHING THE
IT WAS. AN EXTREMELY TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCE. FROM THE VERY FIRST
FIND THAT I WOULD THINK THAT
THE NEED FOR SUPPORT AT SCHOOL
TO THE MOMENT OUR FOURTEEN TO
FIFTY ONE FIFTY. THE REASON I
SUPPORT HAVING. A YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH BOARD IT'S BECAUSE THERE
ARE SO MANY OPPORTUNITIES THAT
YOU VOICE PARTICULARLY ONE LIKE
MY OWN COULD HELP YOU AVOID ALL
OF THIS COMMON THE WE
TRANSFORM. THE WAY THAT I WAS
GIVEN SUPPORT. I COULD HAVE
RECEIVED SUPPORT AND HOW TO
NETWORK OF OTHER YOUTH THE-
WORK WITHOUT MY FOR I COULD
HAVE RECEIVED EDUCATION ABOUT
THERAPY AND EDUCATION HAVE
BEEN. BEEN INFORMED BY WHAT I
WAS INTERESTED MEETING AT THE
TIME I COULD HAVE GIVEN
INFORMATION ABOUT ALTERNATIVE
FORMS OF CARE THAT CAME FROM
THE VIETNAMESE AND CHINESE
COMMUNITY THOUSAND BACK AGAIN.
AND AGAIN COMMUNITIES THAT YOU.
IN MY COMMUNITY- REALLY. NEED-
I TOOK IT BACK OF IT. DEALING
AND FORTUNATELY WE COULD HAVE
CREATED A NUMBER LONG IT
BECAUSE IN OF BEING PUT INTO
THE CAPS CALL A FIFTY ONE FIFTY
IN FORCE THEIR YOU HAVE TO WAIT
THREE. LIFE YOU COULD HAVE HAD.
IN FOR. THE WILD THAT WAS
DEVELOPED BY YOU AND INFORMED
BY YOU. I THOUGHT THE- I'M
SUPPORT. ON THE- I'M SUPPORT OF
OUR ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE THREE-
AND I THINK IT'S TIME TO LET
THINKING YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND I THINK THAT WITH
THE OWN PORTENT FOR YOU TO
REALLY HELP DEVELOP
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR WHAT. THE
**** LOOKS LIKE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- SUPPORTING YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH AND GIVING THEM THE SAME
DECISION MAKING POWER AT THE
ADULT ON BERRICLE COURT AND
VERY IMPORTANTLY TO KEEP THOSE.
SEPARATE OR TECHNIQUE YOU HAVE
THEIR OWN BOARD TO PARTICIPATE
OPENLY- AND WORK TOWARDS. YOU
KNOW DEVELOPING BETTER MENTAL
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH IN
THEIR COMMUNITY- TO- OF. THAT
WANT TO OUT I THINK BE REALLY.
IF WE- ON BUILDING UP THE ORDER
THINKING ABOUT COMMUNITY BASED
PARTICIPATORY RESEARCH AND YOU
PARTICIPATORY ACTION RESEARCH
COMPOSED BECAUSE THEY'RE ROOTED
IN EQUITY AND- BALANCING THE
POWER THAT YOU HAVE WITH THE
ADULTS IN THEIR COMMUNITY- BUT
YEAH. I'M HOPING IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND THANK YOU FROM THE
TIME. GREAT THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I THINK WE HAVE
ANOTHER WITNESS KARINA PAN
OREGON. GOOD AFTERNOON IF YOU
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS TRINA PAN AND I'M A
JUNIOR AT TEMPLE CITY HIGH
SCHOOL LOCATED IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS. I'M HERE TO
SHOW MY WHOLEHEARTED SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY THREE I
RECOGNIZE THAT THE STATE HAS A
READY MADE EFFORTS TO INCREASE
THE MENTAL BEING A STUDENT
HOWEVER ACCORDING TO THE HOPE
IS STILL A VERY REAL PROBLEM
PRODUCING CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS
THE NATION. THE STARK REALITY
THAT MENTAL HEALTH IS ONE OF
THE MOST PRESSING ISSUES THAT
CHILDREN IN YOUR FACE TODAY
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THERE WAS A 38%
INCREASE OF HOSPITAL DISTORTED
FROM MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
AMONG CALIFORNIA YOUTH AGES
FIVE NINETEEN THIRTY TWO ASIDE
AMONG THE H. TEN THE TWENTY
FOUR INCREASED NEARLY 60%
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. EVERYONE IN BY
CHANGES TO THE FOR THE MENTAL
CONDITION EVEN WORSE DURING THE
COPA NINETEEN CONDEMNING AT
LEAST 29% OF CHILDREN AND YOUTH
ARE FACING MENTAL HEALTH THE
COURT. BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND
STATE WHAT ON MY LEARNING THE
MAJORITY OF STUDENTS ARE ABLE
TO COPE WITH THE NORMAL
STRUCTURE THE FLAG AND SCHOOL
AFTER THE PANDEMIC LESS THAN
40% FELT THIS WAY. BOTH
STUDENTS I KNOW I HAVE
EXPERIENCE OF MENTAL ILLNESS
AND I'M NO EXCEPTION THIS PAST
SUMMER I PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED
DECLINE MENTAL HEALTH INTO A
VITAL FALL. UNFORTUNATELY LIKE
MOST USED IN CALIFORNIA I WAS
BLIND TO MY OWN STRUGGLES AND
COULD NOT RECOGNIZE I WAS IN A
VERY UNHEALTHY MENTAL STATE. IT
TOOK ME MONTHS TO FINALLY REACH
OUT FOR HELP AND WILL
PROFESSIONAL THERAPY SESSION
AND GET DIAGNOSED WITH MAJOR
DEPRESSIVE DISORDER. I'VE EVER
COVERED BY MY BUSINESS IDEAS
AND THOUGHTS ON HOW TO PREVENT
THIS FROM HAPPENING TO OTHER
STUDENTS BUT I HAD NO DIRECT
PATH TO VOICE MY CONCERNS AND
LET MYSELF BE HURT.
CONSEQUENTLY ONE OF THE BIGGEST
TAKEAWAYS WITH MY EXPERIENCE OF
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR YOU CAP
REPRESENTATION AND THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH. PEOPLE WHO ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THE DECISIONS THAT
ARE BASED ON A LEGISLATIVE
SCALE OUR MOTION SHOULD BE
HEARD UP LOOK AT. THE PROVIDE
AN INCREDIBLY UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE TO THE CONVERSATION
AND ARE RELEVANT TO MAKE THE
CRITICAL TO INCLUDE UP AND
ACTION FROM COMPETITION.
DRAWING THE TOPIC. ADDITIONAL
MONEY TO CREATE A MENTAL HEALTH.
AND OLDEST. COMPLETELY COMPOSED.
WE THE- AND- WITH YOU ARGUE.
BECAUSE WE WEREN'T. WITH THE
MID. AND HELPFUL. WE ARE. TO
HAVE A DOG RECHTEN. ON THE-
THAT ARE. WITH COULD HAPPEN IN.
ON HEALTH. ADDITIONALLY
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN. TO CREE AND
BONTA MULTIPLE. THAT WE KNOW
WILL DIE. BUT THAT YOU'VE
ARTISTRY. EIGHTY FIVE FROM THE
TWO AND MAKE. LIKE THE- ON A
MUCH. SCALE X. INCREASING
IMPACT. THAT THE- THIS WILL
HAPPEN YOU AND POWER THEM TO.
UP AND SPEAK OUT. ADDITIONALLY
IT IS A SPECIAL YOU TO PLAY
DIRECT ROLE BECAUSE OF THE-
HAPPENED A- ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH. BECAUSE DUE TO LONG.
ACADEMIC IS. IF BY THE- HEALTH.
BROTHER AND ONE IN THE BACK OF
THE QUITE IS ONE OF. THE
PRESSING. THAT CHILDREN IN
YOUTH BASE. INCREASING SIDE OR
HOPELESSNESS AMONG STUDENTS
RELATED TO. DECLINE IN GAME AND
HAVE. AND READING. LANGUAGE AND
MATH. I GREEN PAUL. I DESPITE
HAVE THREE TIME. OUT IN TOWARD
REDUCING THE WITHOUT. IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT AND OF THE- ARE
MORE THAN TWICE AS LIKELY TO
TALK ABOUT. TO THEIR PEERS. NOT
ONLY DOES THE CUTTING OF THE
WHOLE IMPACT. TOWARD BUT ALSO
INCREASES THE CHANCE FOR THE
STUDENT WILL. ATTEND SCHOOL. IF
YOU ARE NOT GIVEN A- FOR IN
THAT THE WHOLE WILL BE IN. TO
THE- THREE OF STUDENTS AND
HEALTH. IF I WERE HARD TO
MENTAL WELLBEING. BY BY VOTING
IN. SUPPORT OF A- FIVE FROM THE
THREE AND GIVEN UP. THE BOYS
THAT WE SOAKED. NEED THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I DON'T BUT-
THERE ARE ANY- WITNESSES IN OP.
READ WITNESS IN OFFICE. WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE CA. FOR
ARE. I MISS WORLD. THANK YOU- I
JUST LIKE THE ALL FOR THIS. YOU
KNOW- HAVING WERE IN THE MEN
HEALTH FOR LONG TIME- I WE
REALIZE THAT. SO MANY- OF THE
UNDIAGNOSED CASES ARE YOU KNOW
YOUNG PEOPLE. ESPECIALLY
PRETEEN. WHEN A LOT OF THESE
ISSUES SERVICE AND THE MORE WE
GET YOUNG PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT
THE ISSUE THE BETTER. AND YOU
KNOW THEN MAYBE. YOU KNOW THE
CONCEPT THAT IT ALL COULD BE
REDUNDANT ARTICLE COULD ALREADY
BE DONE BUT WE CAN SEE IT'S NOT
BEING DONE- WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE YOUNG PEOPLE OUT THERE
TALKING ABOUT IT. BECAUSE
TALKING ABOUT IT IS ONE OF THE
BEST WAYS TO REDUCE STIGMA SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE A COMMENT AND
SAID THAT I'LL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MISTER RODRIGUEZ. S. THANK YOU
MISTER GEORGE WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL FORD OFFICE AS WE LOOK FOR
YOUTH SPECIALLY TRANSITIONING
BACK INTO SCHOOLS I THINK IT'S
MORE IMPORTANT NOW THAN EVER
THAT WE HAVE- RESOURCES LIKE
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELING
SERVICES TO HELP THEM
TRANSITION BACK. OBVIOUSLY IT'S
A BIG ISSUE THERE'S SUFFERED A
LOT FOR THE LAST COUPLE LAST
YEAR SO I'D LOOK FOR SUPPORTING
THIS BILL BRING THIS BILL FOR
DIVIDE THE NECESSARY RESOURCES
TO ARGUE. IS OUR FUTURE THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH THAT WILL GO TO
WITH THAT WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION LAST THE VICE BE
OPEN AND ONCE AGAIN JUST YOUR
NAME POSITION ON THE BILL AND
ANY ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT.
CAME TO STATE YOUR POSITION ON
AB FIVE SEVENTY THREE MIA PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. WE'LL GO FIRST TO
LINE SIXTY SEVEN SIX SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS NUMBER EIGHT NINE THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OTHER TITAN
CHEMICAL THE COMMISSION AND
WE'RE THE PROBLEM ON THURSDAY
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY THREE AND
RECOMMEND YOUR SUPPORT TO
DISPEL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK THANK YOU NEXUS LINE
NINETY SEVEN NINE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IT HAPPENED TODAY AND
YOU'RE CALLING FROM THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER-
CALLING IN TO SHOW OUR WILL
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. GOOD LINE
NINETY THREE NINE THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SISTERS JULIE SNYDER
REPRESENTING THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE- HAVE TO FAIL
IMPRESSED I AM BY THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO TESTIFIED WERE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
MY NINETY NINE NINE NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
JACKIE WALL AND THE STUDENTS
FROM THE HIGH SCHOOL IN SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MY NINETY SIX
NINE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU THIS IS KATIE ANDREW
FROM CHILDREN AL AND STOCK
MARKET AB GREAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANKS CALLER PLEASE. NINE
NINETY EIGHT NINE EIGHT. HI
THIS IS JAY FROM CHATHAM WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATIONS AND
COUNCILS AND ITS STUDENTS FROM
ALL HIGH SCHOOL IN SAN
FRANCISCO- IN SUPPORT AND A
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YOUR LINE ONE OH
ONE ONE HUNDRED ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SORRY ONE ONE IS
YOUR DEVICE ON MUTE. HELLO MY
NAME IS HARPER JOHNSTON I'M A
STUDENT FROM SPEAKING WITH I.
T. HIGH SCHOOL IN SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NO FOR THE
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
OKAY- WITH THAT OF HIS CAREER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING
BACK- WAS SERVING THAT HERE
MOTION OR SECOND MOTION. MOSHE
MISTER FLOOR SECOND BY MR
RODRIGUEZ THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL MEMBERS. WHAT I WHAT I
MAYES. MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BIGELOW. BONTA BURKE. CARILLO
CARILLO HI FLORA LARA AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MEANS AND I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I THIS AREA. RIVAS
RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON HIGH.
AS EIGHT ZERO OKAY THE BILL IS
OUT WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS THAT ON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS KOREA MR MCCARTY A.
B. NINE FORTY. THANK YOU AND
MISTER CHAIR I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB NINE FORTY THAT
COLLEGE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT. WE ALL KNOW THAT- GOING TO
COLLEGE IS STRESSFUL- BUT-
MENTAL HEALTH IS A LITTLE
DISCUSSED- CRISIS THAT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR COLLEGES AND
FRANKLY IT'S ONLY MADE WORSE
DURING THIS DURING THIS LAST
YEAR'S PANDEMIC. A SUICIDE IS
THE SECOND LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH AMONG COLLEGE STUDENTS-
ONE OF FOUR STUDENTS HAVE A
DIAGNOSABLE MENTAL ILLNESS SUCH
AS DEPRESSION. WHICH CAN BE
ADDRESSED WITH STUDENTS REACH
OUT FOR HELP AND MANY TIMES.
THEY HAVE WAIT TIMES THAT CAN
BE DAYS TO WEEKS TO MONTHS AND
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE A BROKEN
ANKLE YOU GO SEE HELP RIGHT
AWAY. SO THIS BILL WOULD
INCREASE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR A CALL STUDENTS. BY
PRIORITIZING MONIES FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
ADMINISTRATIVE FUND- WITH ME
ARE TO STUDENTS FROM-
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITIES FROM
THE CSU SYSTEM. WE HAVE A G.
ONE LOU WITH THE SSA AND MAGGIE
WHITE. WHO'S THE LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH THE CSU SYSTEM
AZCARRAGA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR OUR WITNESSES.
QUAN LI AND MAGGIE WHY. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CARE WOULD
ANDMEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
QUAN LOW AFFECTING YOUR VEHICLE
STATE SPENDING POLITICAL
SCIENCE AND HISTORY AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY ACTION.
REPRESENTING NEARLY HALF A
MILLION IF YOU STUDENTS I'M
HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY NINE
FORTY. THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WILL PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED FUNDING TO ALL TWENTY
THREE CSU CAMPUSES TO EXPAND
OUR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
SIMPLY PUT AB NINE FORTY WILL
RE ALLOCATE MONEY FROM THE
UNDER UTILIZED PROP SIXTY THREE
ADMINISTRATIVE ACCOUNT SO OUR
CAMPUSES CAN HIRE ADDITIONAL
CONCERTS AND BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS
PSYCHOLOGICALLY. THE NEED FOR
ACTION IS CLEAR AS THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY THIS YEAR IF YOU
HAD ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
SYSTEM WIDE WHICH MEANS OUR
COUNSELOR TO STUDENT RATIO IS
ABOUT ONE TO EVERY ONE THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED SIXTY SEVENTH. THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
ACCOUNTANTS ARE WRITTEN
RECOMMENDS THAT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES MAINTAIN A RATIO
OF ONE FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
EVERY ONE THOUSAND TO ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS.
SO IF HE IF HE'S RATIO IS WAY
ABOVE THE RECOMMENDED
GUIDELINES. WHILE THESE NUMBERS
REPRESENT THE PROBLEM AT HAND
OUR STUDENTS LIVED EXPERIENCES
ARE WHAT PERSONIFIES. THE NEED
FOR IMMEDIATE ACTION. THE
REALITY A LACK OF FUNDING FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
REPRESENTS SEE WHAT'S JUDY AT
CAL STATE LA. WHO ISN'T ABLE TO
ACT TIMELY. THAT COULD SAVE
THEIR LIFE OR THE STUDENT AT
HUMBOLDT STATE WHO'S COUNTING
SESSIONS ARE CUT SHORT DUE TO
LIMITED AVAILABILITY. PER
STUDENT AT CAL STATE FULLERTON
IT'S THE WEEKS OF WAITING FOR
HELP ACT COUNSELING AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES.
ULTIMATELY LEAD TO EXHAUSTION
AND EFFECTIVE HELPLESSNESS
LEADING TO ACADEMIC FAILURE.
AND PER RESIDENTIAL ADVISER
ACTING DIEGO STATE AND THAT
HAVING TO CARE FOR STUDENT WITH
CLINICAL DEPRESSION BECAUSE
CAMPUS- ACCOUNTING AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES. TURNED
HER AWAY. STUDENTS FROM ACROSS
OUR TWENTY THREE CSU CAMPUSES
HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB IN
PROMOTING EFFORTS TO DE
STIGMATIZE. ACCESSING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. TODAY'S
SOCIETY PRESSURES THANK A
GLOBAL HEALTH. I CAN
UNCERTAINTY THE RISE IN RATES
INJUSTICES AND UNSTABLE LIVING
ENVIRONMENT. THE PRESSURES
STUDENTS FACE NAY KOBE ON THE
MID TERM EXAM OR CLASS PROJECT.
THESE PRESSURES AFFECT OUR
ABILITY TO SUCCEED IN OUR
ACADEMIC MUCH WHAT'S OUR
HOLISTIC WELLBEING. I THINK WE
ALL KNOW THAT WE MUST ACT ON
THE CRITICAL NEED TO EXPAND THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
COLLEGE STUDENTS. THE REAL
QUESTION IS HOW WE DO THIS. THE
SOLUTION IS EIGHTY NINE FORTY
CAMPUSES NEED ONGOING FUNDING
TO BUILD A SUSTAINABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ADDRESS
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS TO
DATE AND TEN YEARS FROM NOW.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND CLEAN SUPPORT
EIGHTY NINE FORTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND ON TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS. AFTERNOON THANK YOU
FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY I'M NOT
THE RIGHT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY CAMPUS BOX AT.
THE SPONTANEOUS AND YOU'D LIKE
TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY FOR AN ON GOING
DEDICATION TO IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF STUDENTS. EIGHTY NINE
FORTY WILL EXPAND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR ALL PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENT IN THE STATE.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND THE CSU. THESE SYSTEMS ARE
NEARLY THREE MILLION STUDENTS.
THEY ARE OUR FUTURE FINANCIAL
NURSES TEACHERS AND CIVIC AND
BUSINESS LEADERS. IF I INCREASE
SAID ONE TIME ALLOCATIONS OVER
THE PAST THREE YEARS THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT
ADMINISTRATIVE ACCOUNT HADN'T
EXPECTED CARRYOVER BALANCE OF
FORTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES WAITED FOR TEN STATES
THAT PERSONAL INCOME TAX
COLLECTIONS TRANSFERRED TO THE
OVERALL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUNDS JUST LAST MONTH ONE
THIRTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
HIGHER THAN HAD BEEN PREVIOUSLY
FORECASTED. WE BELIEVE THE
ADMIN SIDE CAN AND STUDENTS
NEEDS WITHOUT ANY IMPACT TO
OTHER NECESSARY PROGRAMS. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT MENTAL HEALTH
IS A BASIC NEED FOR OUR
STUDENTS. LIKE HAVING FIFTY AND
A SAFE PLACE TO SLEEP EVEN IF
NOTHING THAT FOR STUDENTS TO BE
ABLE TO FULLY PREPARE STUDIES.
AND COMPRISING. MEMBERS OF THE
WORKFORCE. SH INSURANCE GAVE
THEM AN ACT ADEQUATE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE. HAS BEEN
ONGOING FOR A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
AND THE DEMAND IS ONLY
INCREASING. EIGHTY NINE FORTY
WOULD ALLOW FOR THE HIRING OF
ADDITIONAL COUNSELORS THE
REDUCTION OF WEIGHT TIME
EXPANDED PROGRAMMING AND
SERVICES AND QUITE SIMPLY MORE
ACCESS FOR STUDENTS TO GET THE
HELP THEY NEED WHEN THEY NEED
THAT. RESEARCH INDICATES THAT
THOSE YOUR RECORDING STRUGGLE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ARE
TWICE AS LIKELY TO DROP OUT OF
SCHOOL. AND THREE QUARTERS OF
OUR LIFETIME MENTAL ILLNESS
WILL BEGIN BY AGE TWENTY FOUR.
ADDRESSING THE MENTAL HEALTH.
IS AN IMPORTANT CAR AND STATE
MENTAL HEALTH CONTINUUM OF
CARE. AND COLLEGE CAMPUSES
PRESENT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TARGET A LARGE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS. WITH A HOLISTIC
SUPPORT THEY NEED. IN ORDER TO
ESTABLISH HEALTHY RESPONSES
STRAT. I'D LOVE TO IDENTIFY AND
TREAT MENTAL HEALTH DIAGNOSES.
ALL OF WHICH THAT STUDENTS ON
THE PATH TO A HEALTHIER FUTURE.
I THANK ROUGHLY HIGHLIGHTS AND-
THAT THEY CAN BE I THINK NIGHT
HEALTH. AND IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NOW CALL HEALTH SURVEY. NEARLY
SIX THREE PER OR FEELINGS AND
ALL. AND BY. AND JUST UNDER
TWELVE OF IT EARLY TODAY AT IS
A KEY SUICIDE. THIS CALL THE
NINETEEN CAN HAS ONLY STUDENTS
MENTAL HEALTH. AND THEY'RE
LIKELY LONG TERM IMPACT THAT
WOULD NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
STUDENT COLLEGE CAMPUSES ARE
THE IDEAL PLACE TO CONNECT THEM
WITH THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
THRIVE. AND WITH EIGHTY NINE
FORTY CALIFORNIA COLLEGES WHAT
ARE THE NECESSARY RESOURCES TO
PROVIDE ONGOING SERVICES AND
SUPPORT. FOR ANY OTHER REASON
WE ARE HERE FOR AN EIGHTY NINE
FORTY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. I DO I DO HAVE I
DO HAVE A COMMENT- I JUST LIKE
TO SAY ALL AGREE IN THE COUNTRY
WHEN THE CONCEPT OF- THAT WE
NEED MORE FUNDING FOR- MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN OUR COLLEGE
AND UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES I THINK
THAT'S A GOOD THING- THAT WOULD
AT NOT GETTING WE NEED HIM I
THIK IT'S A GOOD CONCEPT OF
TRYING TO GET IT THERE. I DO
WORRY THAT- WHERE THE SOURCE OF
FUNDS IDENTIFIED IN THE BLL
WILL BE REV REPRESENT EITHER A
LARGE ENOUGH SOURCE OR ALTHOUGH
THERE IS OBVIOUSLY WE'VE HAD A
SWELLING OF OUR COFFERS THIS
YEAR MY BIGGER CONCERN IS ABOUT
SUSTAINABILITY OF FUNDING-
PROFFER ONGOING PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES SO YOU YOU HAVE MY
SUPPORT TODAY. BUT I WOULD BE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT
BECAUSE OF THIS THE OF THE OF
THE OF THE LARGE COFFERS WE
HAVE TODAY DON'T NECESSARILY
TRANSLATE TO THE FUTURE SO-
THAT- WE WILL GO. TO- PUBLIC
COMMENT ACTUALLY AND WE'LL LET
YOU CLUB CLOSER- SOAK WILL OPEN
THE LINES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
AND THIS IS WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR
NAME POSITION AND ANY
ORGANIZATION IF YOU'RE
REPRESENTING ONE SO. PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE. THANK YOU TO
STATE YOUR POSITION- EIGHTEEN
NINE FORTY ME PRESS ONE OF THEM
ZERO AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WELL FIRST IN LINE
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES
RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST YEAR IN
SUPPORT OF THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WHAT A LINE ONE
OR THREE ONE HUNDRED THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
JUSTIN SELLING IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. YOU DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON
THE BILL YET. WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE INTENT WELL I THINK THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSOR FOR BRING IT
FORWARD TO. KEEP WORKING WITH
THEM GOING FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
LINE SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI INTERNET CAN ON
BEHALF OF THE STUDENTS SENATE
PAPA CONNECTING THE COLLEGES
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
NINE FORTY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. FIND
SIXTY TWO SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU AYE FERMAT CALL-ON BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE OH
FOUR ONE HUNDRED FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SORRY ONE OF FOR
YOUR PERSONAL DEVICE ON MUTE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MOVE ON YES
PLEASE MOVE ON. NEXT CALLER
THERE ARE NO FOR THE NINETEEN
Q. AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK-
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
MCCARTY. YEAH THANK YOU- YOU
KNOW I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
ON ON FUNDING AND WE'VE LOOKED
AT THIS IN THE BUDGET AS YOU
KNOW FOR YEARS. AND WE HAD SOME
SUCCESS PUTTING SOME MONEY ONE
TIME. BUT THERE YOU'RE RIGHT
THERE HAS BEEN A SPIKE IN
OVERALL- MONEY COMING INTO PROP
SIXTY THREE THIS YEAR THE
ECONOMY IS BOOMING EVAN DURING
A PANDEMIC. MUCHAS GOING
DIRECTLY TO PROGRAM SINCE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT THERE YEAR
AFTER YEAR EVEN IN THESE BIKES
ARE ALWAYS BEEN- EXTRA ADMIN
FUNDS. AND SO THIS GIVES US THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS IS A STATE
PRIORITY THERE'S BEEN LEFT OVER
FUNDS YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER
YEAR. SO THIS GIVES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALIZE THIS IS
AN UNMET NEED THAT LITERALLY
CAN SAVE LIVES AND SO WITH
THAT- ASK YOUR ABBOTT THANK YOU
CAN CRESCENTA THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISS MCCARTY. THE BILL HAS
A MOTION BY MISTER MAYES IS
THERE A SECOND. SECOND BY MISS
RIVAS THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO HIGHER EDUCATION. MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHEN I WHEN I AM MAYES MAYES I
HAGER CURRY. BIGELOW BONTA
BURKE CARILLO CARILLO I'VE
FLORA LARA AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MCCARTY. MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN. RIVAS RIVAS AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
WALDRON WALDRON I. EIGHT TWO
ZERO EIGHT ZERO THE BILL BILL
PASSES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON A MISS
REAVIS. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS BILL. AB THREE TWENTY SIX
REMOVES THE SUNSET DATE ON THE
CONSUMER PARTICIPATION PROGRAM
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE OR D. MHC. DMH C.
REGULATES THE MAJORITY OF
HEALTH COVERAGE POLICIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ONE OF THEIR
CORE MISSIONS IS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS HEALTH CARE. EVERY
YEAR THIS LEGISLATURE
INTRODUCES ON AVERAGE FIFTY
PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT
AFFECT THE DEPARTMENT AND EACH
MEASURE COULD AFFECT THE TWENTY
SIX MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
SERVED BY THE DEPARTMENT. IN
TWO THOUSAND TO THE CONSUMER
PARTICIPATION PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED TO HELP THE
DEPARTMENT. FULFILL THEIR
MISSION AND SURE CONSUMERS HAVE
A SAY IN THEIR HEALTHCARE
INSURANCE MEDICAL RECORDS AND
MEDICAL DECISIONS SINCE THE
PROGRAM WAS CONSIDERED NEW AND
EXPERIMENTAL. A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET APPLIED TO THE PROGRAM.
AFTER ALMOST TWO DECADES IN
EXISTENCE THE CONSUMER PROGRAM
IS NO LONGER NEW AND
EXPERIMENTAL. EXPOSE
EXPERIMENTAL- BUT RATHER WELL
DEMONSTRATED AND SUCCESSFUL
TOOL FOR PROVIDING CONSUMERS AN
IMPORTANT ADVOCATE IN THEIR
CORNER. BOB TODAY I HAVE WITH
ME- TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT JOSE
TORRES WITH HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL OPEN THE LINE FOR MR
TAURUS TO TESTIFY. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON- CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR SO GOOD AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS
JOSE TORRES ON BEHALF OF HEALTH
ACT CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE
HEALTH CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT AB THREE
TWENTY SIX WHICH WOULD REMOVE
THE FIVE YEAR SUNSET OF THE
CONSUMER PARTICIPATION PROGRAM
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE AND MAKE
THE PRO PROGRAM PERMANENT. THE
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO AND IT ALLOWS FOR
THE IN THE STATE DIRECTOR TO
AWARD REASONABLE ADVOCACY IN
WITNESS FEES. TO ANY PERSON OR
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS
THE INTERESTS OF CONSUMERS. AND
HAS MADE A SUBSTANTIAL
CONTRIBUTION ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMERS. TO THE ADOPTION OF A
REGULATION ORDER OR DECISION BY
THE DIRECTOR IF AN IMPACT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF A RELIEF.
INVASION THAT HIGH RECEIVED THE
AWARDS HI A DAMAGE. TRACK
RECORD. NINETEEN VULNERABLE LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS IMMIGRANTS AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. IN A
PREVIOUS AWARD CONSUMER FOCUSED
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM AND
CONTRIBUTE ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMERS ON VARIOUS TOPICS
SUCH AS THE MERGER BETWEEN CVS
HEALTH AND AETNA ANTHEM AND
CIGNA OTHER TOPICS SUCH AS
TIMELY ACCESS REGULATION
PROCEEDING. AND DEPARTMENT WILL
MAKING REGARDING PLAN
CANCELLATIONS WITH VISIONS OF
NONRENEWABLE. WHEN THE PROGRAM
WAS CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
IT WAS NEW AND EXPERIMENTAL THE
SUNSET CLAUSE HAS SINCE BEEN
EXTENDED MULTIPLE TIMES AND
AFTER NEARLY TWENTY YEARS. IT
IS NO LONGER NEW AND
EXPERIMENTAL. IT ALLOWS FOR
CONSUMERS. ROSTER CONSUMERISM
IN PLACE TO BE INVOLVED IN THE
REAL MAKING DECISION PROCESS.
THE ONSUMER PARTICIPATION
PROGRAM SHOULD BE MADE
PERMANENT WITHIN THE NEED TO
BE. AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
AFTER I VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I BELIEVE THERE
ARE NO OTHER WITNESSES FOR THIS
BILL THIS POINT- WILL OPEN THE-
LINES FOR A WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION JUST.
YOU CAN OPEN THE LINE MISTER
OPERATOR IF THERE ARE ANY CALL
ANY CALLERS OKAY ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. AND OUR FIRST.
PERSON IS LINE EIGHTY FIVE ONE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS SERRA BLOCK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU AND THAT
COMES FROM LINE. ONE OH FIVE
ONE OH FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS WENT AWAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR
AND SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE TO SIX
INCHES THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
THAT COMES TO MIND. EIGHTY SIX
NINE EIGHTY SIX. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANDREA
TERRY REPRESENTING ALL COMMAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND THAT COMES TO
MIND NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN IS YOUR PHONE ON MUTE. BY
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND WE'RE GETTING NO RESPONSE
FROM NINE NINETY SIX AND WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
C. NINE WOULD YOU LIKE THE
CLOSENESS RIVAS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION. MOST
FAMOUS CARILLO SECOND BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY. MOTION ONCE AGAIN
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW. BONTA
BURKE REAL CARRILLO FIVE FLORA.
FLORIDA VOTING. MAIENSCHEIN.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN
RIVAS RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. WALDRON
WALDRON I. EIGHT ZERO K. YOUR
BILL IS OUT WILL ALLOW OTHERS
OUT ON LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN SO
THANK YOU GO AHEAD AND TURN
THIS OVER TO MY CO CHAIR MY
VICE CHAIR. MOVING ON TO YOU-
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY THREE DOCTOR WHAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY THE SUPREME COURT
HEARD ORAL ARGUMENTS IN THE
MOST RECENT ATTACK ON THE
FEDERAL AFFORDABLE CARE ACT THE
SUPREME COURT FINDING IN FAVOR
OF THE CHALLENGE POTENTIALLY
COULD RESULT. IN THE ACABEING
OVERTURNED IN ITS ENTIRETY OR
IN SOME COMPONENTS OF THE ACA
BEING STRUCK DOWN. THIS IS
PROBLEMATIC FOR MANY REASONS
ONE OF WHICH IS THAT HEALTH
INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS IN STATE
LAW TIED BACK TO THE ACA. FOR
EXAMPLE THE ESTABLISH OF
MINIMUM ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS AND THE PROHIBITION
AGAINST PRE EXISTING CONDITIONS
THESE PROVISIONS IN FEDERAL LAW
AND SURE PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. THE BILL
THIS BILL TO LEASE LANGUAGE
THAT CONDITIONS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CERTAIN ACA
PROVISIONS ONLY TO THE EXTENT
AS REQUIRED BY THE FEDERAL ACA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I HAVE WITH ME
WITNESSES DIANA DOUGLAS WITH
HEALTH ACCESS IN ON THE PHONE
AND TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. DO
YOU HAVE A MOTION A SECOND WILL
MOVE TO THE WITNESSES. GOOD
AFTERNOON BY TURN MEMBERS DIANA
DOUGLAS FOR HEALTH ACT
CALIFORNIA STATE WHAT
HEALTHCARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION TO SUPPORT EIGHTY
FOUR NINETY THREE. WHICH
REMOVED FROM CALIFORNIA STATUTE
THAT MAKE YOU CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS CONTINGENT UPON THE
FEDERAL INDIVIDUAL MANDATE FROM
WE NEED OUTDATED HYDROXYL
PRESERVE THE CRITICAL
PROTECTIONS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
RELYING ON INCRIMINATE RELIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA LAW. AND FEDERAL
LAW PRIOR TO THE PASSAGE OF THE
ACA HEALTH PLANS COULD
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST A PRE
EXISTING CONDITION RENDERING
THEM UNSURE UNINSURABLE AND
APPOINTEES DISCRIMINATORY. RATE
SETTING PRACTICES. NOW THAT WE
HAVE BEEN HOW BRITISH HAVE OUT
AND HOW HAS ENACT ITS OWN
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE IT'S TIME TO
REMOVE THESE OUTDATED
CONNECTIONS TO OUR FEDERAL
STATUTE. FOR THESE REASONS WE
SUPPORT EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
THREE AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR ACCOUNT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THINK MR LISTED HERE
ANYBODY ELSE THE WITNESS US
ANOTHER WITNESSES ARE THERE ANY
ADD ONS AND SUPPORT. GO TO THE
PHONE LINES IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT
AND WE HAVE OUR FIRST PERSON
COMES ON LINE FIFTY EIGHT BY
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON GENTLEMEN BEHALF
OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. GREAT THANK
YOU DO IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE ON
THIS ITEM. THESE ARE JUST ADD
ON'S INSTEAD NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TO
ARE THERE ANY- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. HEARING GALLON ONE
THEN ZERO. ARE THERE ARE THERE
ANY BUT ANYBODY THAT WITH THE
THAT'S THE MEMBER THE PUBLIC
THAT WISHES TO BE TO BE IN
OPPOSITION. RIGHT HEARING NOW
WILL COME BACK TO THE KILLING
CLEANUP. THANK YOU- WILL COME
BACK TO COMMITTEE IF ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NINE
WE DID HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND I JUST CAN'T REMEMBER
WHO MADE THE MOTION. IS THAT
AGUIAR-CURRY IN THE SECOND BY-
BY MR RODRIGUEZ. AND DOCTOR
WOULD LIKE CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO
PASS. I WOULD I WOULD I MAYES
AYE MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW. BONTA
BURKE CARILLO. CARILLO AYE LARA.
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY. NAZARIAN
RIVAS RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ EYES SANTIAGO.
WALDRON WALDRON HIGH. SEVENTIES
ONE MORE. OKAY WILL BE THE WILL
BE VERY LOW. YES. THE ONE WHO.
BIGELOW NOW. SHE. IF YOU. YEAH
LIKE THE MEMBERS TO COME TO THE
CHAMBER PLEASE WE DO HAVE ONE
BILL ON CALL- WE NEED TO LIFT
THE COURT WELL LET'S LET'S
LET'S SAID GO THROUGH THE
BILLS- MEMBERS ARE COMING DOWN
I RESPECT THE MEMBERS THAT ARE
HERE BUT OTHER MEMBERS PLEASE
COME TO THE CHAMBERS SO THAT WE
CAN. ADD YOUR VOTES TO THE- TO
THE AGENDA HERE TODAY SO- BILL
AB TWELVE FORTY TWO TWELVE
FIFTY TWO BY MISTER CHOW PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BONTA BURKE
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY. NAZARIAN
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ HI SANTIAGO.
WALDRON. IS ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB. TWELVE FIFTY TWO. WHAT ARE
NOT VOTING. MCCARTY MCCARTY I.
SEVEN ONE STILL NEEDS ONE MORE
OKAY WILL BE THE BILL ON CALL-
THE- CONSENT CALENDAR- PLEASE
LISTEN- OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BONTA
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI.
THIRTEEN SO THIRTEEN I WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON A MOVIE TO
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB EIGHT THREE
EIGHTY ONE DAVIES PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE- AND- CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE NAZARIAN SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
I. THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB THREE
FORTY TWO GIPSON PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING. BONTA
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WALDRON
WALDRON I. TWELVE ZERO TWO ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOVING ON
TO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON ITEM NUMBER
TEN EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY THREE-
EXCUSE ME ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
TWO SIXTY FIVE MISS
PETRIE-NORRIS PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW I. BONTA.
NAZARIAN SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE
WALDRON WALDRON I'D. THIRTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH ITEM
NUMBER TEN EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY
THREE MISS CARILLO PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NONVOTING BONTA BURKE.
NAZARIAN SANTIAGO CENTER HIGH
TEN ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE- PLEASE
COULD. OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS LATELY BELIEVE
IN THE ROLL UP IN A NUMBER TEN
EXCUSE ME SO ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO BONTA. BURKE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
NAZARIAN. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI.
ELEVEN ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER AND
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN THROUGH
OTHERS CAN ADD ON ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB THREE TWENTY SIX
MISS REAVIS- PLEASE OPEN ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BIGELOW BIGELOW NOW BONTA.
BURKE. MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I NAZARIAN. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I.
TEN TO ONE TEN TO ONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHER STAT ON AND-
WILL LIFT THE CALL ON EIGHTY
FOUR NINETY THREE WOULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. BONTA BURKE
FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN SANTIAGO WHATEVER I.
SENATOR OF TEN ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE'VE GONE THROUGH
EVERYTHING AT THIS POINT- AND
WE'LL GO THROUGH IT WILL GO
THROUGH GO THROUGH GET A WE
HAVE A COUPLE MEMBERS WE
HAVEN'T SEEN TODAY- SO THOSE
MEMBERS PLEASE COME WE WILL
LEAVE WE WILL WE WILL GO FIVE
MORE MINUTES HE DO NOT COME IN
VOTE YOUR HE WILL BE REFLECTED
AS NOT PRESENT SO- WILL GO
AHEAD AND- GO BACK TO THE- GO
BACK THROUGH THIS AGAIN- START
WITH THE- WILL START THE TOP-
HAVE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE-
OPEN THE ROLL CALL. THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR ARE ACTUALLY OPEN
THE ROLE ON ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB. TWELVE FIFTY TWO- MISTER OF
BIGELOW WOULD LIKE TO CHANGES
VOTE ON THAT. WHEN NOBODY TO
NOW BIGELOW NOT VOTING TO KNOW
ON AB TWELVE FIFTY TWO ON AB
TWELVE FIFTY TWO OKAY SO- WITH
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BONTA. BURKE
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN I.
NAZARIAN SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I.
NINETY TWO BILLS OUT NINE TO
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN- A. B.
THREE EIGHTY ONE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR DAVIES OPEN THE ROLL CALL
OF THE ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE.
BONTA NAZARIAN. K. ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB THREE FORTY TO PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BONTA NAZARIAN. THE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWO SIXTY
FIVE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MR BONTA THIRTY
MIN AGO THE ONE. BURKE AB TWO
SIXTY FIVE BONTA. BONTA I'D-
NAZARIAN. FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER TEN
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY THREE
CARILLO PLEASE CARILLO PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE
BURKE I. NAZARIAN. I DON'T
NUMBER TWELVE ELEVEN THIRTEEN
ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO THANK YOU A
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE A. B. NINE
FORTY MCCARTY PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE. BURKE I.
MISSOURIAN NAZARIAN AYE FIFTEEN
ZERO. OKAY ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
AB THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE.
BURKE I. NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE.
FOURTEEN ONE FOURTEEN ONE ITEM
NUMBER- FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY THREE WOULD PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BONTA BUT I BURKE
BURKE I FOR A. FOUR NINETY
THREE. NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE.
THIRTEEN TO ONE THIRTEEN TO ONE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BONTA BONTA HI
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE FIFTEEN
ZERO FIFTEEN ZERO THANK YOU AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO THE TOP OF THE
LIST AGAIN- ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB TWELVE FIFTY TWO CHAO PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE UP SO
THAT WAS THE SERVER JUST ADDING
NEXT WITH THAT DID PASS SO
WE'LL LOOK TO OPEN THE ROLE ADD
ADD THE ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE. NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE FORT. ELEVEN TWO
TWO SEVEN TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY ONE DAVIES PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE IN THAT- CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA. BONTA HI
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE FIFTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU FIFTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB THREE FORTY
TWO GIPSON PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA.
BONTA AYE NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN
AYE. FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY
TWO SIXTY FIVE PETRIE-NORRIS
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THIS AREA. I
NAZARIAN AYE FIFTEEN ZERO ZERO
AND THEN FINALLY A. B. FIVE
SEVENTY THREE ITEM NUMBER TEN
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE RIGHT FOURTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS
FOURTEEN ZERO WITH THAT WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND CONCLUDE THE
BUSINESS OF THE ASSEMBLY
AUTOMATED SYSTEM OF MASSACRE
LIPS WITH A SECOND. HANG ON.
I'M SORRY ON. A. B. NINE FORTY
IT'S FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN I'M
SORRY FOURTEEN ONE FOURTEEN ONE
OKAY. VERY GOOD OKAY ALL RIGHT
THE MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.